[Music]
so today we canceled dr susie diembo who
you may remember as the mulleted
communications professor who appeared on
my episode of dr phil she has been quite
silent publicly ever since that episode
aired probably because she embarrassed
herself to such an unfortunate degree in
fact she embarrassed herself even more
than viewers of the show realized
because her worst moments were left on
the cutting room floor which she should
be grateful for
well now she's back this time on dr
phil's podcast to reflect on that
experience and also to explain why i'm
such a horrible and wrong and evil
person now you notice how she waits
until i'm three thousand miles away
before she tries to make this case with
with me safely out of the the room and
out of the state
she can launch her missiles
which she does throughout the course of
an hour-long interview we'll play just a
few clips starting with this piece from
the beginning of the discussion listen
to this
why is this such a divisive issue
because i think it is a divisive issue
yeah no i think you're totally right and
and it's good to talk about this example
in addition to what you said because
it's an example of how i
approach communication and conflict in
general
um
it it's
well there's at least two reasons it's
divisive uh first you have people like
matt walsh and his team
capitalizing and exploiting the very
real uncertainty that people can feel
and face when there is a culture change
like this
for me
i think it makes total sense to have
people
be um fearful around something like
gender pronouns
or personal pronouns and
to feel
anxiety
when they learn about that
because it can question their
fundamental core beliefs
so this is an example of how she
approaches
communication and conflict she says she
approaches communication and conflict
by waiting three weeks to come up with
any kind of counter-argument to someone
and then at that point presenting the
counterargument um
while the other person is out of the
room
that's her communication and conflict
resolution strategy as someone who is an
expert in the field
she also again as a communications
expert
immediately attacks her opponent's
perceived motivations
rather than addressing the actual
arguments
and you're gonna you're gonna notice
that throughout the into all the clips
we play is that that's all she does is
go after what she perceives to be my
motivation while saying nothing about
the arguments that i presented
in this case she says that i'm
exploitative
i'm exploiting the fear that people feel
when they quote learn about personal
pronouns because this new information is
causing them to quote question their
core beliefs
okay well first of all nobody is
learning about personal pronouns for the
first time
um no one learned about pronouns from dr
phil
no one is learning about pronouns from
the you know the the gender ideologues
we already knew about that
we aren't confused by pronouns or afraid
of them
we're all quite familiar with the
concept it is you susie who are confused
see you think that words are your little
pets which you can
take personal ownership of
and you think that the meaning of words
is entirely subjective that each person
can make up their own meaning as they go
along but what you don't understand as a
communications professor is that if
language is entirely subjective
if there's no set definition for these
words then communication is impossible
because literally the whole point of
language has just been removed causing
communication to collapse and break down
you know there has to be a shared
understanding of what the words mean
or
there's no way to convey meaning to
anybody
if we all have our own meaning for the
words that we're using
so when you say that a man is a she
and i ask you what do you mean by that
how is that person a she and you have no
answer for that question you have made
communication impossible because you are
using words apart from their objective
meaning without any idea of what your
new meaning even is
you have not put anything forward
that causes anyone to question their
core beliefs at no point have you or
anyone on your side or anyone who pushes
gender ideology ever said anything that
makes someone go wow that's a great
point i never thought of it like that
sending them into some kind of
existential crisis where they begin to
reanalyze everything they thought they
knew this has never happened
because nothing that you say means
anything if you're causing people to
question their core beliefs it's not by
presenting arguments but it's by
berating and cajoling and threatening
and coercing them
into giving up their core beliefs
out of fear of social alienation and
shame
so then so then who exactly is
exploiting fear in this case well uh one
thing i can tell you as a four-star chef
myself um amateur chef but i consider
myself a four-star chef your kitchen is
not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami coda kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikota also uses
steel source for mills in japan and each
blade is crafted using techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each kamikota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hearty blades uh polishing and
sharpening them to an excruciatingly
fine edge each knife is individually
inspected kamikoto is so confident that
their knives will work for you that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single bevel edge
kamikoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter that is
guaranteed
kamikoto is currently having a massive
extended new year sale and on top of
that sale you can get an additional 50
50 off any purchase you make with
discount code mattwall so click the link
below or go to kamikoda.com matt walsh
and use promo code matt walsh to save an
extra 50 today
let's uh listen to the next clip
and it's really frustrating to me too
especially around uh you know the the
pronoun episode and that react the
reaction that people had to that
so you
you laying out uh the how vast your
audience is
means you are the perfect platform to
present multiple viewpoints um in my
view because you're reaching the most
people um
and
you the way
we need to hear
both of the or both many different sides
of an issue so that people can make a
decision for themselves and when we shut
down people from or from hearing other
kinds of perspectives it's just that
productive to me and it's really boring
and uh it's usually motivated by uh the
need for validation from one side that's
not uh genuine in my view i mean i could
go on and on about this uh
especially with regard to our episode
but
um
i don't agree i mean i think that
providing that platform is a good thing
some on that on your show i wonder if
maybe i didn't do my job well enough
because they think that he won
and i was like
i didn't think that
yeah well you i mean you said it there
not me if if if it makes you feel better
susie you did have an impossible job um
you did lose you know the argument but
your job was to defend and legitimize
something that is fundamentally
incoherent there's no way to do that
there's no way to win that argument the
only way that you win is if the other
side surrenders ahead of time
and that's what you've come to expect
from these conversations because it's
what most people do
it didn't happen in our case and that's
why you were so flustered
she said in the earlier clip that when
she's talking to her students especially
those from rural areas and introducing
the gender pronoun concept to them that
she's introducing something that they've
never heard before
you know but that's not true as we
covered everyone has heard of pronouns
before
and the more familiar you are with the
concept and with the rules of grammar
generally the more impervious you are to
the nonsense that people like susie and
her ilk spew on the subject
but speaking of people being introduced
to things for the first time it is susie
and the people on her side who have
literally never been challenged on their
views by anyone ever in their lives
that's why they collapse so easily
that's why they run away claiming that
they've been traumatized
people on my side
we've all this is the advantage that we
have
we've all heard and confronted gender
ideology a million times we can't escape
it
so you can't surprise us we've heard all
of it we hear we hear all of this every
day
everywhere we go how could we not it's
everywhere there is no bubble available
where you can go inside it and escape
this nonsense
but these people they all live in
bubbles where the opposing side does not
exist that's actually available to them
that's an option
most of the time
and that's why they're so unprepared to
deal with challenges
the reason people thought that i won the
argument is because well because i want
it
but i want it simply because i asked
questions about the opposing side's
position
which nobody on the opposing side could
answer because they've never been asked
those questions before
because for most of them on that stage
and most of them generally it's probably
like the first time they've ever even
had a conversation with someone who
disagrees with them
let's uh let's listen to one more clip
here
you did a good thing by i didn't really
know who matt welsh was that well before
i went on the show but i'm real glad
that i did that and that you had him on
because
people need to hear
the what he is talking about now my
dilemma and i've been thinking about
this since the show and i don't know
that i'll have a concrete answer for you
yet but it's been on my mind is how i
think it's important to have him on and
um
i wish uh he does they don't play fair
he's not playing fair he's yelling and
and uh
so i've been try sorting through the
dilemma of how to get people to actually
listen to the words he's saying
and with me i don't care if you if
you're conservative thinking or you
don't like personal pronouns it's not
the outcome it's how he got to that
outcome because his argument made no
sense
and it was exploiting fear and it was a
lot of generalizations
um and that's why i feel like you needed
to have him on
so good because i want people to hear
that now i don't know that that happened
okay well she wants people to hear my
argument she says well
we can agree on that point at least i
want people to hear them too
though she says that i didn't play fair
because i was yelling
except i never yelled at any point
during that episode
and and this is how you know you lost
the argument by the way
if after the fact you're complaining
that your opponent wasn't being fair
it's like i said
at the beginning that this if once you
start complaining about the refs
you know after the games we're saying it
wasn't fair this is they missed that
call they should you know your team lost
now if i had run up and snatched all
their microphones or something and said
ah you can't say anything
that might qualify as not playing fair
that also would have been kind of funny
and i might as well take their
microphones because they weren't saying
anything anyway
but far from snatching their microphones
i was actually inviting them to speak
more
by asking them questions about their
position
they could not answer those questions
because their position is fundamentally
incoherent
which is not my fault don't take it out
of me susie
but for now i do have to say
to susie d'ambo that you are once again
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated